les faits se sont déroulées le 14
décembre 2019 rue Nationale à Tours le
gérant d'un tabac presse s'est braqué
par un jeunessedf il exige des
cigarettes et la caisse et là tout
dérape le propriétaire se retrouve
l'arté d'une dizaine de coups de couteau
le procès aux assises de cette agresseur
va se dérouler jusqu'à vendredi soir
romain Delville a suivi la première
journée d'audience compte rendu
à la longueur du couteau j'ai compris
que cet homme venait pour nous faire du
mal quels sont les mots de Jean-Pierre
garruchez le gérant du quai d'Iv le
tabac du milieu de la rue Nationale à
Tours le 14 décembre 2019 à 8h25 lui et
son épouse son braqués dans leur
commerce et sont victimes de coups de
couteau cet après-midi les images de
vidéosurveillant sont replongées le
couple dans cette matinée où tout a
failli basculer il m'a tapé deux fois du
côté gauche
et m'a touché des poumons après
puis il m'a planté surtout dans le dos
parce que comme on était assez on devait
être serré
l'un contre l'autre pour se défendre
lui pour pouvoir avoir l'argent et puis
moi ne pas lui en donner donc
voilà et ça a duré combien de temps je
ne sais rien parce que il m'avait
12 coups de couteau ça commence à faire
l'accusé lui est présentée par sa
famille son père et sa tante comme un
jeune sans éducation influençable
menteur mais pas violent ni agressif
sans abri au moment des faits
aujourd'hui
âgé de 24 ans l'accusé et selon son
avocate un garçon qui s'est perdu j'ai
un client qui comparait dans la cour
avec une maturité beaucoup plus
importante qu'au début de l'instruction
et qui est extrêmement peur de
s'expliquer d'avoir à faire aux victimes
c'est voilà quelque chose qui terrifiait
mais il entend il entend voilà pouvoir
parler pour parler de sa vie pour leur
parler des faits c'était important pour
lui de pouvoir donner sa version de
l'ensemble des faits le butin une
centaine d'euros et 9 cartouches de
cigarettes pour volama armée tentative
de meurtre l'accusé risque 30 ans de
réclusion criminelle le verdict est
attendu demain dans la soirée